we mentioned elon musk before the uh the
left is still in the midst of its of its
meltdown uh over this and here is an
msnbc segment with um
al sharpton
who still somehow has a show on msnbc
that i guess some people watch i don't
know how they could keep this show going
if nobody watched it i can't imagine
can you imagine sitting down for an hour
and choosing to watch al sharpton i
can't
some people do though and here's what
they had to say about elon musk
tesla ceo alana uh musk who has made a
43 billion dollar offer for twitter to
quote build an arena for free speech
musk has accused twitter of censoring
its users are you concerned that what
musk is trying to do is to open up the
platform for more misinformation about
topics such as covert 19 and the 2020
election and perhaps even allow former
president trump to get his account back
i mean i'm going to be honest elon musk
is a danger to twitter and to freedom of
speech he has been known to say some of
the most transphobic and homophobic
things to his millions of followers so
creating an arena for hate to me that's
what that sounds like an opportunity for
him to have no consequences to have no
flags for people just to be able to do
whatever it is and say whatever they
want with regardless of what kind of um
harm that it causes so i think that this
is something that folks really need to
be paying attention to because i think
that elon musk buying twitter or
creating this quote unquote arena would
be problematic
did al sharpton just give elon musk a
gender transition it sounds like he said
ilana musk
i could be wrong and that's maybe that
that's one way that elon musk could
solve all this this problem for himself
if he just rebranded himself to elana
musk had a gender transition came out as
a woman
you know he's trans now he's already an
african-american immigrant that that
that apparently hasn't hasn't helped him
much
in the uh
in the court of public opinion but if he
was a tr i mean if he was a trans
african-american immigrant
then come on he's got way too many
victim points at that at that point you
have to just let him take twitter um
she says that the guest there says that
elon musk is a danger to twitter
and to free speech
now on the first
note she's
she's she's right actually
he is a danger to twitter as it is
currently
assembled
he is a danger to twitter as it is as it
currently functions
he's certainly a danger to the to
twitter's corrupt board
um he's a danger in that way but that's
that's that's a good thing
that's called being he's another way of
putting us he's a he's an actual
disrupter
and there are a lot of people get credit
for being disruptors who aren't but in
this case that's actually what elon musk
is
and she also says that he's a danger to
free speech and it's a little confusing
to follow the logic here because
she says he's a danger to free speech
because
he would turn
twitter into an arena where you could
say whatever you want
no matter how much it hurts people's
feelings
well hold on a second
he's a danger to free speech because
he'll allow people to say whatever they
want
that doesn't seem to make any sense at
all does it and and in fact it doesn't
and the reason why it doesn't make any
sense and it's totally incoherent
and all of our conversations really
about anything uh descend so quickly
into incoherence is that
you know the framework for the
conversation
we're starting from a faulty premise
and in this case the faulty premise is
that everybody cares about free speech
which they don't
maybe there would be some chance of us
having
you know a debate
some kind of productive debate in this
country
if everybody was just honest from the
beginning about what they actually want
and what they believe
so on the left
they don't care at all about free speech
so just say that
you know
make your argument against free speech
i'm not going to going to agree with it
but that's your argument
rather than arguing against free speech
within the context of pretending that
you're trying to defend free speech well
there's just no hope of anything
happening there
no hope of us understanding each other
so for the msnbc panelist there her
actual view is that free speech is bad
and she doesn't think we should have it
we should not be able to just say
whatever we want
and okay
start that's your starting point
make your case
i'll listen to that at least because
this i can't listen to
i'm not going to listen to you pretend
that um you're trying to protect free
speech by abolishing it that doesn't
make any sense
but if you could make some kind of at
least coherent
uh robust argument against free speech
i'll at least i'll listen to you
[Music]
you can have a hard time convincing me
but i'll i will listen
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content